first of all, where it will be necessary, an
operational suspension of water is already organized for this purpose,
Ukrzaliznytsia tanks and
cars are also used, that is, different situations, but all the
work is already underway regarding the
wells, we believe that the wells are needed as
soon as possible by the
military administration of the city
civil administration to do for
this yesterday the government accepted  all the necessary
financing solutions have been allocated. That is, we
think that in the coming days, where it is
needed, where there is already project
documentation, where there are already necessary solutions,
all this will be done by
two security guards somewhere at the plant.
Now, if you take Kherson, where there are
the most residents, then it is 5 meters  34 cm
is back, for example, half an hour ago, this
figure was 5.32 before that 5.31 5:29
every half hour there is 1-2 cm now
added they did it deliberately they
blew up the dam they destroyed the
Kahovsky Reservoir to make it impossible
for us to advance from this direction at this time
This period of time that this gives them this gives
their release thousands or tens of thousands of
soldiers who were holding the front line along
this coast. They can now
significantly reduce the number of their
soldiers there and can redirect them
in other directions they absolutely wait on the
population on the people on the people in  to the
temporarily occupied Crimean
peninsula, to the people in the temporarily
occupied territories of Kherson,
Zaporozhye regions, on the other side, and the
Dnipro, er, to them, it is secondary, in the first
place, military reasons